what was the Stanford study on benefits
ah so yeah this is this is one of those
examples of like science validating
something we know intuitively um
Stanford and Berkeley in other places
did these studies on the subject of awe
and if you've seen my videos you know
that this is something I cite repeatedly
but basically uh is an experience
described as one of such perceptual
vastness right such perceptual expansion
that the mental models of the world that
you usually rely upon to categorize
things as happening to you it's the bid
there isn't done that's of the idol -
like oh yeah that's a light oh yeah
that's a person yeah yeah I've seen
those kinds of shirts before oh yeah
it's just another sunset right but
occasionally you encounter something
that's not in your maps as of now those
maps you've built throughout your life
to categorize and put things into order
you encounter something that doesn't fit
into those maps and it can be something
that's genuinely outside those maps or
you can be in an altered state of
consciousness that makes you see
something that was already in the maps
but you're seeing it from a vastly
different vantage point either/or
the point is that during those
experiences you have to now accommodate
yourself enter into a new relationship
with this thing and in that act right he
calls it the dialectical pattern of
reconcilable estrangement this is David
lensing google it but it's creating you
know the experience offers a distance
between this thing and you and then your
new relationship with it closes that
distance and that act we experience
subjectively as ah this particular
Rhapsody is awe-inspiring paralyzing
opie ated adjacency where you're cracked
open and the light gets in like Leonard
Cohen says right like these moments of
off I mean they're they're awesome but
they they're not just pleasurable in
that moment but like I said before they
heal us because after the fact the
studies found people report increased
feelings of well-being increased
feelings of compassion increased
feelings of creativity
and yeah those three oh and the
experience acts as an anti-inflammatory
so it has all these like markers in your
body that it's actually it's it's good
for you so all will bring us closer
together as is everything like the
people the people the people in the in
the studies about all were in Berkeley
and Stanford but then the studies that
are coming out now treating people with
PTSD anxiety and depression with
psychedelics the stuff from Johns
Hopkins University in the Imperial
College of London and Michael Pollan
wrote about in his new book these
studies say that the healing takes place
only when people experience a mystical
experience while under these molecules
and if you look at the hallmarks if you
fill the questionnaire the william james
questionnaire of a mystical experience
all of the attributes mimic or mirror
the experience of all that i was just
talking about before a feeling of the
sacred a feeling of communion with the
cosmos the feelings of infinite
connection with other human beings a
feeling of well-being feeling of noetic
truth of ultimate reality being revealed
right so mystical experience is mediated
by psychedelics treating people who are
sick from depression and anxiety with
treatment resistance right the more
mystical the experience the more they
report the healing weeks and months
afterwards same with people who
experience aw that doesn't necessarily
have to be mediated by psychedelics it
can be the birth of a child that can be
seeing the Grand Canyon for the first
time you can see making love to somebody
new it can be travelling yeah the whole
point is that we need to pay more
attention to what happens to us that is
so healing during these moments that are
seen so you know economically nonuseful
yeah right right you you get obsessed
with that flower it's not bringing you a
thousand dollars no no
that's but that's what's so interesting
yes oh so it's like we're so obsessed
with productivity now and we encourage
the use of substances that promote
productivity like caffeine and readily
but I think we're gonna have to state
pay start paying more attention to these
other domains of mind
the ecstatic domains and then I'm not
the only person saying this by any means
I mean this is where Michael Pollan
talked about in his book this is what
the book stealing fire that day me wheel
and Steven Kotler wrote that was also a
best-seller we need to pay more
attention to the ecstatic and
increasingly as we give up our jobs to
automation in the future which is
happening we're gonna have more we don't
have to find more creative and hopefully
more joyous ways to fill our time is it
better to find The Ecstatic in things
that are not necessarily mundane so
rather than finding its ecstatic moments
in the mundane can we craft things that
are not yet discovered by humans and
that be our ecstasy is there one that's
better I mean it for me the ultimate one
would be something like the end of the
movie contact like if we were able to
make a portal to the other end of the
galaxy and witness celestial events
outside of space and time and talk to
aliens that would be pretty
awe-inspiring one of my favorite lines
about that movie is precisely when she
says they should have sent a poet they
should have sent Carl Sagan but yeah man
I mean that's what we need that we need
to start doing that like journeys
without and journeys within right let's
go explore the solar system and let's
like create virtual reality engines and
combination with new and Theo genic
molecules and explore the inner solar
system - like I I'm more interested in
what's next
in terms of that like what's the next
baseline what's the next base line L so
what's the next what's the next level of
like immersive art like what happens
when it is of theater meets VR meets
like maybe certain molecules that make
you more suggestible and and and
facilitate the suspension of disbelief
you know and and that because you know
this the sky's the limit I think in
terms of the future of
of art you know so with within this art
500 years ago we saw Michelangelo take
years to sculpt such of David years to
make the Sistine Chapel we 500 years
later we are so heavily addicted to
instant gratification are we gonna how
do you see us transcending that you're
talking about the consequences of
increasingly limited attention spans
because we're always getting hit with
like the next dopamine hit on the top of
our social media we used to spend years
making of one piece of art and what well
he did well a lot of a lot of people did
there you have tapestries paintings
sculptures filled or things used to take
years yeah I mean I guess the
consequence that now everybody can be
can participate in the global
conversation whether it's by writing or
publishing or making art means everybody
has access but it also means there's
more noise and more mediocrity yes
everybody's a Michelangelo so that's
always that's like the trade-off right
everybody has a voice but a lot of like
non interesting voices crowd your feed
so that you barely ever see anything
magnificent anymore but everybody has a
voice that's the hi Zoe
so maybe maybe maybe I don't know maybe
there there there that's maybe the role
of curation and maybe there happens to
be a new focus on excellence yes